hello welcome back to the YouTube gaming
stage right here at PAX Prime I'm your
host Daniel dwyer from kingsport calm
and oh my god cliff duszynski is here
what's up to you hello sir flesh it
realizes to be projected hello I am
Bruce a pleasure to meet you sir hey you
guys are here which means you're ready
to talk about your new video game bosque
it's it's out there you have a name you
have a trader and now gameplay you've
been teaching gamers for like a year
like now we got a lil here's a little
gun here's a little character here's a
screenshot that looks like a Bigfoot
video Yeah right and then finally this
morning 6am boom you want some gameplay
you got some [ __ ] game plans all I'm
nice a nice thing to wake up to i'm sure
yeah i mean we're still half awake right
now it's like riding the adrenaline of
ratio of like people who love the game
to trolls is about thirty to one what's
right pretty impressive nice yeah okay
low breakers what's it all about for
folks haven't seen the trailer yet
sci-fi first-person shooters set a
hundred years in the future it's two
sides organized law enforcement versus
the organized gangs imagine if Cyrus and
the Warriors had ever been killed
old-school reference right there and
they're all breaking the law of gravity
so law vs breakers 100 years in the
future crazy environmental gravity all
sorts of inverted gravity zero gravity
low gravity grappling hooks jetpacks it
and all sorts of things we haven't even
revealed yet when people think about a
clip pazsitzky game you go back to like
gears of war with the chainsaw gone you
go back to under a tournament and it's
just like jazz Jackrabbit yeah well okay
maybe something doesn't like crazy guns
and different like like mutators and
ways to play the game yeah sort of the
main mission for this game when I look
at what's in the market it's the whole
thing of like counter-programming if
they do this in movies but like there's
gonna be a manly action will be hitting
that weekend they'll deliver least a
Nicholas Sparks rom-com or something
like that right so when we were doing
unreal we saw quake was deep dark
dungeons without a lot of color we did
on Rio which was bright colors and kind
of more fantastical worlds and here when
we look what we're doing lawbreakers
right now this character based
five-on-five first-person shooters it's
really blowing up and I look at the old
grim dark of killzone that he did gears
that I did yeah it's like war is hell
war never changes or maybe it does and
then over here you have league and over
watch if you're super bright pics are
looking and that's cool but
that's not us we're kind of halfway
between the two and we think there's
room for that X so when you were first
coming up with with lawbreakers the
space was kind of a little bit different
because like you said now there is a
couple of more of these games and like
where Randy pitcher it's gonna be on
later to talking about his game and like
when you do when you haven't sat down
and played these games sometimes it's
difficult to really differentiate
between them yeah like what's the main
way you guys are like differentiating
lawbreakers what kind of makes it stand
I thought there's a the art style first
and foremost I think it's our variable
gravity that we're playing within our
movement I think when it comes to our
universe you know I appreciate a lot of
what these games are doing right now
where it's a space gorilla next to a
tree and next to an eye self that's
their thing I mean it's Lee gets all
that it's cool but I wanted something
that was a little more cohesive for our
world where you know you have organized
law enforcement organized gangs it looks
like good guys versus bad guys and even
within that their sub factions that make
sense so you have multiple people who
are Japanese Yakuza on the breakers you
have multiple people who are the
futuristic DEA on the law side instead
of just [ __ ] everything works yeah
and a nice diverse character sprite as
well as exactly i mean you know when we
started building this game with our
first person shooter heritage we
realized we had up something character
based but we didn't want to do a mobo
MOBAs are great smite is actually my jam
but there's so many out there like if
you're making them over right now good
luck because it's gonna be tough yeah
yeah I think the big thing for me was as
well that's you know we wanted to do
something that's more realistic right so
but not be constrained as much as we
were and all just kind of super
realistic a right where it's all kind of
like real weapons or real bullets better
than all the ar-15 yeah so so my last
game was battle through the hardline
right it's crazy right you can't do
anything because everybody will be
analyzing these guns etc so you know I'd
like that's kind of enabling that the
crazy defense is he behind it that
enables a lot of kind of creativity that
that actually goes back all the way to
the first first version shooters that
we're way way more creative like double
jumps and dodges and vol Jang so that
when there was no rules yeah and when
you weren't trying to imitate real life
which this generation of streaming and
YouTube gamers don't remember because
that's young yeah we announced the game
in this game were tweeting me he's like
oh you got the team fortress 2 rocket
jump I'm like give me yeah like come on
but it's okay because every 10 and 15 10
for 10 in 15 years you can taste
something that's older do a new spin on
it and it's
use new to an entire generation so let's
talk about that let's talk about the
movement aspect it's not to me it's very
much something I remember playing unreal
tournament back in 99 was that you could
like do double taps to the side dodges
and whatnot and every jumps so talk
about the gravity the moon's exploded it
have [ __ ] gravity what's going on and
how does the player interact with that
well so as I said gravity is like the
sum of its parts it's the way that
players have their own abilities such as
dodging double jumping dashing grappling
hooks jet packs like tribes at all that
it's in the environment as well so in
the levels of working on this often one
unique gravity zone in the level that
we're showing off tomorrow and Sunday
there's a lunar gravity section in the
middle oh wow and the beauty of this is
that when you go through it you can
rocket jump and get extra momentum but
in this game you can blind fire in first
person so it's kind of like you know
when Sandra Bullock use the fire
extinguisher in gravity you can kind of
project yourself forward and so you see
in the gameplay trailer breacher shoots
behind him yeah not only is he pushing
himself forward with the force of the
bullets but he's also taking out kid
Sunni so the whole thing is the
combination of the parts of this game of
the abilities the characters the verbs
yields great YouTube videos and animated
gifts and it's interesting that you're
going to be that dangerous but level
design as well because like not to
constantly be harping back with my
nostalgia fix on Unreal Tournament but
like levels where there was like unique
areas like Oh get trapped in that room
and then you explain get inflated and we
want to find that halfway point between
you know crazy abstract quake castles
but I don't want to do the battlefield
has to be a city street yeah you know
and it's like a city street if you think
about it's actually a very boring play
space it's a trench and so something in
the fiction that I rework I'm not ready
to reveal where there's knows no cars on
the streets anymore in the future it's
very walkable open green spaces yeah
excellent and I figure everything right
so we are so fair very vertical that's a
you know there was a question on the on
Twitter the other day like you know it's
the istick rippling who able to hook up
to everything like yeah you know you can
actually go up the roofs again of go
beyond to go around the level I do it
all just kind of crazy things you know
we kind of glue free and that's it that
sense as well anyone saying you've
stolen the grappling hook can break to
multiply
well I mean it goes back to three wave
CTF okay and most gamers these days are
too young to remember that and anybody
who's old enough to remember it is happy
to have it come back and it's not just a
simple grapple go to that location it's
unlike spider-man 2 like that type [ __ ]
momentum we're gonna hit on the side of
a pole and then swing around and gain
momentum and even grapple to enemies as
you saw in the video and we found out
two weeks ago you can grapple the
teammates so we had three kit Sunnis the
first one goes out the second one
grapples and they all just like have a
daisy chain across the map and that's
the kind of emergent gameplay we've
found with it when you hold the ctrl
button you blind fire if you're a
breacher you have a shoulder-mounted
rocket launcher and you hit cue to
launching rockets it fires backwards the
programmers are like I don't remember
coating that but it just works just have
em er yeah that's cool emergency urgent
game design how much as good as many
verbs together and see what happens
nothing like users break it and so let's
talk about the characters thing and how
do they break down it must be difficult
to sort of you know but people think
about these things in terms of like Oh
assassin tank healer like that's the way
I think about classes or what I'm how
are you breaking down these different
characters I mean if when our ardian
talks about somewhat realistic it's like
we wanted aspirational characters that
people could feel represented by you
know when you see katsuni she looks like
this cool badass girl but she also has
you can kind of a little kill bill T&A
on that right when you look at Chronos
he's the big boys almost bein looking
dude you know you can kind of identify
with it yeah it's-- randy pitchford i'm
like sentient monster man you have a
sentient mushroom some of that it's cold
oh but that's that's that direction for
that game that's that Allison wonder
like crazy now we're not that and that's
okay so is it is it a player on player
5v5 what's the one of the modes gonna be
like 55 we're showing off one mode
tomorrow and Sunday it's essentially
called overcharge we're in the middle of
the map there's a battery so this
mysterious element you're trying to
charge up bring it back Stadium hey you
know it's a it's a useful thing in
science fiction pterygium and once you
charge it fully in your base to score
point however the battery can be taken
out of your base at any point and
brought to the enemy's base okay you
have to stand on it for a few seconds
get rid of the shield kind of like
capture at home but we found is there's
some crazy back-and-forth or last-second
saves and everyone's punching each other
in the shoulder and yelling awesome I
want to think about both you both of
their games you all
then have like lots of different modes
very own traditional modes as well going
back to thinking about a tournament and
even Gears of War like yeah pioneered
stuff that hasn't been really fine that
generally all unless you're called duty
with a billion people install base if
you have a medium-sized install base 3
game types is using Scott right now
because you know the other modes are not
played anymore right I think that that's
the same thing with levels right we can
release 50 levels with 20 modes and then
you know yeah what do people play well
team deathmatch on one map don't know
exactly yeah don't even morpheus yeah so
I'm so what was this i guess like you're
doing a lot here that's different you're
doing you know on the face of it you
about different characters the way that
you're utilizing gravity for the
missions and wanted levels wanna and
then different game modes as well is
there is there a worried that maybe if
you're doing too much you're like almost
like the players won't know what to grab
on to do what's what's the sort of the
gravel I see is just gave me no I mean
from a production standpoint we're 40
people right so we want to stay small
medium so it's only one year in so we
built this team as we build the game and
what we have i'm pretty proud of what
everybody's accomplished that said each
character's almost could be their own
star of their own game like this could
be the duty dishonored right so we're
finding that one of the things in order
to get the game done is you know we need
to be symmetrical so we're going to be a
symmetrical game you know when you play
the game here at the off-site impacts
you know there it's Chronos and kitsuna
on one side of the breakers it's
breacher and maverick on the law massive
the asymmetrical the final version will
be much more symmetrical to be one on
each side but female pneumatically
different yeah and levels are a
symmetrical as well completely so you
know there's no advantage is only on
each site right it's a bleep mirror some
help it's a and so how many characters
do you think you're gonna have obviously
were unveiled how many was in the
trailer was a five different car in the
trailer we're targeting you know for
each side five six ish but this game's
gonna be living products you know I
already have ideas for the characters
and the gangs and the factions that I
want to introduce a year oh yeah you
know and new game mechanics and
completely ruin the game's balance so
you guys can all yell at us and tell us
we suck so we can then fix it again are
you gonna get into eSports red as well
you know competitive gaming has changed
a lot since you gotta walk before you
run man yeah lady sports is huge
everyone's trying to push it too soon
don't put the cart before the horse get
a version of the game out keep building
that community and then hopefully make
the magic leap hmm what's it like for
both of you considering you're coming
from these massive franchises you've
like basically creative and then like
evolved over years to then be back at
square one starting something new again
yeah I love it right so it's always sort
of having to run like three other people
teams where everything is kind of
digested and any of the tiniest blocks
and it's no creatively anymore it feels
like right because they all needs to be
produced etc now we write we have such a
small team there everybody into
interacting with each other very closely
so somebody coats a new feature right
there hey I can do it like this and they
walk over to the designer and they can
spin on it they present two clips like
the amazing let's do it right and that's
kind of dynamism it's really great but I
think you know the key thing is all for
us it's just focus right we focus on on
the thing and we focus on you know it'll
arena multiplayer right you're not doing
single-player we're not doing cutscenes
we're not making the game you know
require two other people so you know and
we can always grow kind of later but you
know the core of the game is that
multiplayer right what what do people
playing Call of Duty and Battlefield and
kills on and you know for the longest
time no the player right so that's what
we're focusing on and then you know 40
people purely on multiplayer is a good
team right let's say and you to these
inside one with some half of them here
there's like a bunch of them hanging out
I mean it's the same before we started
you know look out for people who are
wearing the break free shirts for kind
of information on the off site we got
little cards to get you in there
although its first come first serve it's
one of those things they sit in front of
a screen all day long maybe they'll have
a meeting like when they go to this show
and they see be filled be hands-on with
it its momentum that carries you through
the rest of the year and the thing I
love about this guy is we tend to have a
little bit of coarse language at the at
the studio yeah yes two phrases that are
very useful i suggest learning life okay
first one is [ __ ] something ok i'm
thinking about doing this in like bucket
I'll code it let's do it oh my god is
what's management gonna say oh my god
and the other one is if somebody's
wasting our time or if there's some BS
[ __ ] off ok don't ain't nobody got time
for that
[ __ ] it and [ __ ] off yeah the region
making it must feel good that way
because you probably have a lot more
ownership over something when it's 40
people like I'm sure you guys do is
creative leads but like for the rest of
your team as well well I mean it really
part of the game you have to be a bit
defiant from likely these are the three
pillars you if you don't like it [ __ ]
off nobody's going I want to make a
dinosaur fighting game I like MOBAs I
like then like no this is the game
here's we're going and it started as my
baby it's now a year and it's become the
company's teenager yeah and when it
comes out for pre-alpha release and
final release it's gonna be the
community's adult that's amazing I think
you guys already have a playable here
well not here but offside offside it set
up 128 belmont a beast who Oakland
diamond people just wander and walk
right up it's this really nice on the
menu yeah feels like it's a sex club by
night or something but does it ignore
ignore the horse masks is it it doesn't
have we a bunch of weird masks all right
like some eyes wide shut [ __ ] okay i
might go down there later thanks
gorgeous yeah yeah yeah dude for
research exactly yeah i can expense this
right mr. exactly and i guess when will
this be playable then for people like
it's kind of crazy to be asking this
question but you were already it's only
being here and you're showing it to some
people so why when you're looking at out
we are steadily collecting like relevant
information for those who would want to
be in a nun pre-alpha through our
mailing list and everything like that
and there will be kind of a mailing for
early access for gamers hopefully early
next year yeah cool thickly I don't know
if something works get it in your hands
what's it coming out on pc first pc
first and i think Sony and Microsoft are
currently yelling at each other alright
we're only 40 people no I likes to love
consoles you know if the time is right
we'll find the right partner to help us
poured it we can't do it ourselves so
we'll talk to Sony you know talk to Phil
talk to Adam we'll see if we can make
something happen and finally before I
let you guys go I'm sure you got a bunch
of people to talk to what does it feel
like to finally be able to talk about
this and is there a lot of pressure
because you're both coming from you know
stories franchises that will talk about
these cool as a cucumber we did our
twitch twitch livestream to announce the
game and normally when I do the [ __ ]
it's like hey what's up and I'm they're
all watching me I'm like I didn't eat
for like two days
I mean there's something romantic about
the fact that we made jazz Jackrabbit
together over 20 years so you did yeah
that's how we met all right I was like
17 he was a high tea huh a lot younger
long time ago and getting any back to
get me up and I was like dude like the
thing about rd honest he can run the
company but also a programmer can't
[ __ ] them yeah it's like oh you
that's impossible screw you I'll code it
now and there's a tremendous amount of
respect that people get for that and I
think we have a great kind of you know
team going on right now and the feeling
of having something new it's like Pixar
if we're not nervous we're not doing our
jobs and it is so satisfying to see this
yeah equity agree it's a you know and
then things right it's been such an
exhilarating ride already because you
know it's a year right should we started
yeah and a year ago there was nobody in
the office right we didn't have desks
right that kind of stuff computers were
not there people aren't laptops and you
know during that year we kept on hiring
people they were actually able to do
this you know in that time frame right
if you look at any other game like you
know horizon you know I worked on that
well it will be before i left guerrilla
games that's five years ago wow really
so that was under you know you know
undercover for such a long time right
the same thing with all the other games
and you know we already kind of showing
a lot more engaging with the community a
lot more and this to start really right
now we can talk about games you can talk
you know get people in playing right
through telemetry student development
where developers the smartest people
you'll ever meet but they're very
insecure about their intelligence
schemes so I can pitch Batman to anybody
and maybe like that's dumb and like no
like when you get Scott Snyder or
Christopher Nolan on it they make it
amazing yeah so anything everything is
in the execution developers just need to
sometimes say that could go either way
try it will iterate and be quick and
quick and we'll make the call awesome
and as gamers were all very fascinated
and excited to see hello breakers turns
out thank you so much pleasure meet you
sir Pitt paczynski pleasure and for all
the folks who are watching online at
what else you freak teasing out over the
weekend because you do more trailers
coming out I know this is gonna be it
for a little while but now that
everyone's going to see the build add
our offsite 128 belmont ave east when
you finish your session after if you
enter your twitter handle it's going to
generate anime am animated gif of your
best kill oh go auto dump it to your
twitter if you want excellent so that's
the thing it grates awesome animated
gifs
and now we're actually going to be able
to just stream the game from our studio
perfectly not just going to see the
gameplay trailer you saw gonna see Scott
are amazing LD messing people up yeah
awesome are you gonna play Unreal
Tournament when it comes out as well I
knew him oh sure I mean I live stream
gears with the wife yeah that was cool
so I'm gonna start getting a streaming a
little bit more often i need to do it's
just you can't ignore it cool dog huge
be involved doc you just get a little ol
D major the little Evie might be come on
you might be in my face licking up on my
face smashing a gentleman thank you so
much going on right dad appreciate it I
thanks everyone for and watching our
show here today I will be back real soon
right here on the YouTube gaming show at
PAX Prime stay tuned